it's a common sight a truck traveling
along the highway
but the drivers not steering like in a
science fiction film at daimler the
future of trucking has already begun
this demonstration as part of a
technology event on an unopened motorway
section near magdeburg has caused a
sensation in freight haulage Wolfgang
ban heart head of Daimler Trucks says
the mercedes-benz future truck 2025
represents the company's vision for
transport and long-distance services a
decade from now for years Daimler has
been one of the leading companies in
active and passive driving assistance
systems for both cars and trucks with
safety systems including proximity
control assist stop and go assist active
brake assist 3 and Lane Keeping Assist
these trucks already offer a high level
of safety but what is now being
demonstrated goes even further
that I got a man hug says this is a
world premiere a truck that can drive
autonomously that means it can drive oh
my itself at 80 km/h without the driver
having to steer it can accelerate or
break stays right in the lane and is
very very safe autonomous driving is
made possible by networking and
augmenting existing technology with
cameras and radar sensors when the
message appears on the display the
driver can activate the system and turn
his seat 45 degrees away from the
steering wheel thanks to the so-called
highway pilot the truck can now travel
without driver input this system can
adjust to a wide variety of driving
situations for example if an emergency
vehicle approaches it can automatically
pull over to the right to allow it to
pass and then return to the lane without
driver intervention the driver can still
take over at any time but how do
truckers feel about that sis Terrance
patent hunts roofed is a truck driver he
says the new system is good and less
stressful once you get used to it it
takes some time to get used to letting
go of the steering wheel and taking your
eye off the road by letting the truck
take care of the driving he says he has
time to take care of other activities in
the cattlemen fallen infatti booted Curt
Hutton for house under today guidance
attune cameras and radar sensors around
the vehicle enable drivers to pay
attention to other things but there's no
word from Daimler as to what this
technology will cost autonomous driving
is ready for use in everyday trucking
operations freight haulers that watch
the road promise to make long-distance
transport safer